HIGH WIRE ACT AS WE BRING YOU
ALL OF THESE BREAKING STORIES
BUT WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH
THREATS AND TRUTH.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
>> FIVE YEARS AGO, SPEAKER VISIT
TAIWAN.
IT WAS COMPLETELY WRONG.
THE U.S. DRAW A LESSON FROM IT
INSTEAD OF MAKING REPEATED
MISTAKES.
>> Laura: IT'S NOW, WELL, LET ME
JUST TELL YOU ONE THING.
10:00 A.M. IN TAIWAN AND, TO HER
CREDIT, NANCY PELOSI DIDN'T BACK
DOWN WHEN CHINA ESSENTIALLY
THREATENED TO SHOOT HER PLANE
OUT OF THE SKY.
NOW SHE'S BEEN THE GROUND FOR
WHAT, ABOUT 12 HOURS OR SO
LANDING HERE JUST AFTER 10:30
A.M. EASTERN TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING YOU NEWS
ABOUT THE SPECIFICS OF HER
MEETINGS AT ANY MOMENT.
NOW, REMEMBER, TRIP DETAILS HAVE
BEEN LARGELY KEPT UNDER WRAPS
DUE TO THE SECURITY CONCERNS.
BUT BY GOING AHEAD WITH THIS
TRIP, NANCY PELOSI IS DEFYING
THE WHITE HOUSE AND IGNORING THE
THREATS MADE BY CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY LEADERSHIP.
>> SOVEREIGNTY CANNOT BE
INFRINGED AND CHAI KNEES PEOPLE
CANNOT BE HUMILIATED AND CHINA
CANNOT BE STOPPED, THE POA WILL
NOT STAY IDLE.
>> Laura: NOW THINK ABOUT ALL
THOSE AMERICAN COMPANIES LIKE
NIKE AND ALL THE HEDGE FUNDERS
LIKE LARRY, THE BILLIONS THEY
MAKE IN CHINA, THE COUNTRY THAT
CONSIDERS A BRIEF VISIT BY NANCY
PELOSI, WITH A LONG-TIME ALLY
LIKE TAIWAN A HUMILIATION.
AND THEN IT USES IT AS A PRETEXT
TO ACTIVATE ITS MILITARY.
NOW SPEAKER PELOSI HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT SUPPORTING THE
CCP IS INCONSISTENT WITH MODERN
DAY LIBERALISM.
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS MOST IN
THE ESTABLISHMENT, THEY DIDN'T
GET ANGRY WITH CHINA, THEY GOT
ANGRY WITH PELOSI.
>> THERE WAS NO IMMEDIATE REASON
WHY THE SPEAKER HAD TO GO TO
TAIWAN.
THERE'S NO CHANGE IN THE
FUNDAMENTALS OF U.S. POLICY.
>> RIGHT NOW IS A TIME TO HAVE
GOOD RELATIONS WITH CHINA, OPEN
DIALOGUE, AND NOT DOING ANYTHING
TO PROVOKE THEM.
I WOULDN'T BE POKING THE BEAR
RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: DON'T POKE THE BEAR.
WELL, MITCH McCONNELL AND SOME
OF THE MORE ESTABLISHMENT-TYPE
REPUBLICANS STOOD UP TO THE PRC.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THE SPEAKER DID GO TO TAIWAN.
I DON'T THINK THE CHINESE GET TO
TELL MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHERE
THEY CAN GO.
>> Laura: NOW, THIS MOMENT HAS
FORCED THE ESTABLISHMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SOME VERY UNPLEASANT
TRUTHS ABOUT CHINA THAT THEY'VE
TRIED TO KEEP HIDDEN FOR YEARS.
PRESIDENT XI IS AN EVIL DICTATOR
WHO DOESN'T WANT TO JUST CRUSH
TAIWAN JUST AS HE CRUSHED HONG
KONG, BUT ULTIMATELY HE WANTS TO
DOMINATE US AS WELL.
YET THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
THEY STILL REFUSE TO GRASP OR
RESPOND TO THIS THREAT.
NOW THIS JUST ISN'T THE OPINION
OF THE ANGLE, LISTEN TO OBAMA'S
FORMER AMBASSADOR TO CHINA.
>> POOR JOE BIDEN LOOKS WEAK
BECAUSE HE EITHER TOLD HER NOT
TO GO LOOKS WEAK IN THE CHINESE
EYES OR HE'S WEAK BECAUSE HE
TOLD HER NOT TO GO AND SHE
WASN'T ANYWAY AND THAT MAKES US
LOOK A LITTLE BIT WEAK TO THE
CHINESE.
CHINESE UNDERSTAND STRENGTHS
BETTER THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY
AND THEY CAN SMELL WEAKNESS A
HUNDRED MILES AWAY.
>> Laura: AND WEAKNESS IS WHAT
THEY'RE SMELLING HERE.
FOR THE WEEK LEADING UP TO
PELOSI LANDING IN TAIWAN, THE
PENTAGON AND THE WHITE HOUSE
WERE PANICKING AND WAVING HER
OFF.
THE FACT IS, THEY ALL KNOW WE
AREN'T READY FOR A CONFLICT WITH
CHINA.
THEY JUST DIDN'T WANT US TO KNOW
THAT.
BUT NOW WE DO, DESPITE OUR
$800 BILLION PER YEAR IN
MILITARY SPENDING, WHICH IS NOT
PREPARED FOR PRESIDENT XI'S
CHALLENGE.
NOW THANKS TO CHINA'S ADMISSION
INTO THE WORLD TRADE
ORGANIZATION 21 YEARS AGO, AND
OUR IDIOTIC TRADE POLICY PRE
TRUMP, CHINA NOW HAS A LARGER
STANDING ARMY THAN WE HAVE.
MARINATE ON THAT FOR A SECOND.
SO BOTTOM LINE, ALL THE
ESTABLISHMENT'S CODDLING OF THE
CCP HAS EMPOWERED THEM AND
WEAKENED US.
AND NOW WE FIND OURSELVES MORE
VULNERABLE MILITARILY AND
ECONOMICALLY.
AND ALL THESE SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES WE'RE DEALING WITH EXPOSE
HOW STUPID AND HOW RECKLESS OUR
ESTABLISHMENT WAS.
BUT NOW ISN'T A TIME TO JUST CRY
OVER ALL THE SPILLED MILK.
IF YOU THINK WE ARE TOO DEPEND
ONTO CHINA FOR KEY SUPPLIES THEN
IT'S TIME FOR US TO BUILD NEW
SUPPLY CHAINS.
IF YOU THINK WE NEED A ARMY THAT
HASN'T BEEN WHO WILL ODD OUT BY
WOKENESS THEN IT'S TIME TO
REFORM THE MILITARY.
IF YOU THINK THAT THE CHINESE
ARE PREPARED TO SACRIFICE FOR
THEIR COUNTRY AND YET WE
AMERICANS ARE NOT PREPARED TO DO
SO FOR OUR OWN, THEN LET'S THINK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN START TEACHING
YOUNG PEOPLE TO LOVE AMERICA
INSTEAD OF HATING HER.
BUT DON'T KEEP PRETENDING THAT
WE CAN GIVE IN TO PRESIDENT XI'S
DEMANDS OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WITHOUT THOSE DEMANDS GETTING
WORSE.
TODAY HE'S TELLING US WHO CAN
VISIT TAIWAN, TOMORROW HE MAY BE
TELLING US WHAT WE CAN SAY ABOUT
CHINA, EVEN AT HOME.
NOW THIS IS ALREADY HAPPENED IN
THE FILM INDUSTRY, HASN'T IT?
THE FUTURE OF AMERICA BELONGS TO
THE POLITICAL MOVEMENT THAT BEST
RECOGNIZES THE DANGER OF
PRESIDENT XI AND FIGURES OUT THE
BEST STRATEGY TO KEEP US ALL
LIVING FROM CHINA'S VICE GRIP.
AND, BY THE WAY, DON'T, FOR A
MOMENT, FALL IN WITH ANY OF THE
CYNICS WHO SAY, OH, WE CAN'T
UNTANGLE FROM CHINA AT THIS
POINT.
WE'RE TOO E MEGSED WITH CHINA.
THEY'RE WRONG.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT DELIVERED
THE HIGHEST STANDARD OF LIVING
IN THE WORLD, OVER 320 MILLION
PEOPLE FROM ALL DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND ETHNICITIES.
THEY HAVE A GIANT PRISON CAMP.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I DON'T
KNOW, WINNIE THE POOH CAN GET
YOU SENT AWAY FOR YEARS.
YEAH WE'VE BEEN SLOPPY AND YEAH
WE'VE MADE MISTAKES.
BUT INSTEAD OF WINING ABOUT HOW
HOPELESS OUR POSITION IS, THE
TIME HAS COME FOR ALL OF US TO
LIVE IN THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE FACING.
>> THERE IS JUST NO COUNTRY THAT
PRESENTS A BROADER THREAT TO OUR
IDEAS, OUR INNOVATION, AND OUR
ECONOMIC SECURITY, THAN CHINA.
>> Laura: FINALLY THAT GUY'S
RIGHT ABOUT SOMETHING.
AND, OF COURSE, XI MAKES
MISTAKES AS WELL.
THE MORE HE ISSUES THREATS, THE
BETTER AMERICA'S GOING TO LOOK.
IF YOU LIVE IN KOREA OR JAPAN OR
INDIA OR AUSTRALIA OR NEW
ZEALAND, YOU SHOULD BE THINKING,
UH-OH, WE COULD BE NEXT.
UNLESS THAT IS THE AMERICANS ARE
STRONG ENOUGH TO HOLD THEM OFF.
SO THIS ISN'T A DAY FOR HAND
RINGING, NOT EVEN A DAY FOR
RECRIMINATIONS AGAINST ALL THOSE
POLITICIANS, YOU KNOW WHO YOU
ARE BY THE WAY, BOTH PARTIES WHO
THE WHOLE CHINA SITUATION.
TODAY IS A DAY TO COME TO TERMS
THAT PRESIDENT XI AND THE CCP
ARE THE SINGLE MOST DANGEROUS
THREAT TO US AND THE WORLD AND